this is a production of Cornell
University
so today I'm here to talk to you about I
tried to focus on one aspect and I'm
gonna mostly tell this story about the
work that I've been doing with culinary
herb production in controlled
environments and so why culinary herbs
well first there's gonna be a low
barrier to entry
compared to your high wire crops like
your cucumbers and tomatoes and that's
gonna be related to those floriculture
growers or may be interested in
retrofitting their facilities trying to
get into food crops or for new food crop
producers who are learning how to grow
in a controlled environment when you've
got a four-week crop time you can afford
to make more mistakes and it's not quite
as costly in addition that short-term
production cycle is also useful for
patching into a traditional greenhouse
crop program it can serve as a gap crop
when you're looking from maybe
poinsettias through to spring that
holiday season it can serve a purpose
during that time of the year and also
it's increasing in popularity as people
are getting more interested in food
cooking and food crops culinary herbs
come along with that but a lot of it
also has to do with the value of the
crop itself and it's the third most
valuable controlled environment
agriculture crop behind tomatoes and
cucumbers and if you just look at some
trends from 1998 to 2014 you're going
from 194 two producers producing around
31 million up to over 2,000 producers
and just south of 800 million for a
value in that crop and so it is a
high-value horticultural crop so that's
increasing the relevance of this crop
not only among consumers but mostly for
commercial producers they see this as a
potential revenue stream when you think
about what sort of resources you have or
what sort of resources commercial
growers have to support greenhouse crop
production what do they have so Neil
mentioned my academic background but
before I went back to graduate school I
was actually a commercial grower I'm
still a grower at heart I started out
with a two-way split and I asked for an
extension appointment because I wanted
to work with growers for me it's all
about the crops and it's all about
producing these plants and so I like
these resources like last night Kendra
we were talking about the resources
available to growers so what sort of
resources do you have you know we've got
books on poinsettias we've got books on
bulbs we have tomes of information on
certain crops but what is there for
culinary herb production so when you go
in google search for hydroponic herbs
give the results that you get kicked
back as an untenured professor with Iowa
State University property you know you
don't get a whole lot on culinary herbs
so when you sit back and you think about
how can you support commercial producers
what sort of information do they need to
sufficiently grow a crop profitably and
of high enough quality there's a number
of things from cultivars all the way to
marketing that need attention that need
good peer-reviewed science to provide
sound data for them to make their
decisions those decisions that predict
their affect their livelihood and we're
looking at heating costs or crop cycles
I don't specialize in all of these areas
what I did is I sort of picked those
areas that I'm most interested in and
today I'm going to be talking about
cultivar selection production systems
some nutrient solution work and then
light and temperature those were the
areas that I felt I had the strongest
value to bring from my background in
research and from my own interest as a
scientist so this is what I just wanted
to start to generate data that would
support the commercial production of
culinary herbs so when we start out in
cultivar selection for some species such
as basil there's dozens of cultivars
that are available for other species of
culinary herbs there's going to be
relatively few cultivars that are
available to choose from and jonathon
early today we were talking about
strawberry production and you're talking
about how there needs to be some
breeding for cultivars for the
greenhouse and it's the same thing with
herbs there needs to be some targeted
breeding for controlled environment crop
production but there's not and so as a
result we need to utilize those genetics
that are existing on the marketplace and
figure out what sort of genetics bred
for the field work well in the
greenhouse
so the first CEA project I did on
hydroponic herbs was at the
master-student Kelly Walters was just
getting rid of finish up a PhD at
Michigan State but we started out by
looking at 35 different basil cultivars
and we looked at two different
production systems but I'm just going to
focus right now on the cultivars and so
we got these 35 cultivars across a
number of different basil classes of
course we got the sweet basil but we
also had the purple or the opal Basil's
large leaf Basil's cinnamon Thai Bush
lemon and holy basil so we tried to get
a wide variety of basil cultivars to
evaluate their productivity in a
controlled environment
and here we have just a selection of
those results okay so we've got one
cultivar from each of the different
classes and we've got the fresh mass
leaf index and the branch number and
then below here you can see images of
the different leaves from these
cultivars and so this is just meant to
demonstrate the variability among the
different types of basil that we have
when it comes to the amount of
productivity than the size of the leaves
of these plants but let's focus on sweet
basil so here we've got over a dozen
sweet basil cultivars from aroma
- superb oh and sweet basil we've got
the fresh mass and the height and the
leaf index and the branch number but
really horticulture sells the most
valuable packaged water that's really
what we sell is we sell packaged water
we sell fresh mass and so that's gonna
be something that's going to be of
probably one of the most important
things to commercial producers and when
you look at the variation in cultivars
Emilee producing 15 grams in one plant
after three weeks of finishing verses
Italian largely of producing over 50
grams that's over three times the
increase in yield just from depending on
what seed you sow and this example I
actually got to use in Iowa I had a
commercial grower that big they grow
tomatoes but they also grow basil I
think they want to be a commercial
bruschetta producer but they were
talking about their yields and and I
asked him what they were getting I said
well what cultivar you grow said well we
grow Emily and so this is an example
where I said well there's a number of
other cultivars
you can just you don't need to change
anything your production system you just
need to change the genetics that you're
selecting and you're going to be able to
have a pretty dramatic impact on your
yield you know this is a relatively
straightforward and simple experiment or
trial but the value of having data again
to support this decision-making is
important leap index is a proxy for leaf
area and the reason we measured leaf
index is if you had those tasty little
lettuce wraps at PF Changs
where you put the ground chicken
sometimes you can make these specialty
things in large leaves and so we're
trying to measure the leaf size or a
quick measurement for more specialty
uses of leaf index
yeah the larger the leaf it was just
instead of it was sparing Kelly running
them all through a leaf area meter um so
again don't underestimate the importance
of cultivar selection this is the
simplest way to improve your yield now
you do have lower yielding cultivars
that we had in this study and those are
going to be acceptable for growers if
they can get a premium on that price so
for example some of the lower yielding
like the citrus flavored Basil's the
lemons the limes they're lower yielding
but there's a higher premium on those
prices or some of the Thai Basil's so
those lower yielding cultivars can be
acceptable assuming you get the price
back on the lower productivity so just
like you have a choice of cultivars to
select what are you going to grow them
in now there are a number of suitable
systems for hydroponic herb production
the two most popular are going to be
recirculating water culture systems like
the NFT system nutrient film technique
or then the raft or the deep flow
technique system I call that the DFT
system and here we have a commercial
shot this is actually a greenhouse that
was converting from ornamental
production with their Dutch trays into
NFT lettuce production and this is green
city growers outside of Cleveland Ohio
this is one of their basil cons the
rafter that deep flow technique and
again these are the two systems that are
most well suited to leafy crop
production so we wanted to again compare
these two different systems so we had
our own DFT systems in our own NFT
systems these were smaller systems so we
could replicate them and have
of each independently this is also what
we drew all those cultivars in and there
are a few differences are our DFT you'll
notice that it's elevated because I
wanted to make a really sound scientific
comparison I wanted to have the exact
same light intensity at plant height and
so we brought our D F T's up off the
ground so they would be at the same
height as the NF T so we didn't have any
confounding factors we also had a heater
chiller that was keeping the water
temperature the same DF T's can
sometimes be warmer because they'll hold
a larger mass of water that'll hold that
heat in them so he tried to correct for
those potentially confounding variables
to compare these systems and when we
looked at the effect of cultivar again
those 35 cultivars and systems and then
the interaction of cultivar a by system
these are the results that we got and
the data that I just showed you before
it's it's inherent that we would have
variations in cultivars that's why we
have all those different types but the
lack of an effective system and more
interestingly or more importantly the
lack of a cultivar by system interaction
means that growers have flexibility in
which system they can select now there
are differences between NFT systems and
DFT systems again you get comparable
growth but there are some differences as
far as the ease of maintenance
I look at NF T's and being from
Minnesota the land of 10,000 lakes NF
T's are the land of hundreds of
potential leaks with all the tubing that
are on them yeah so there's a little bit
more plumbing involved in them but
there's some ease as far as lifting up
the channels and bringing them to
harvest and sanitized rafts those are
really nice because again you can lift
up that raft for a harvest and if you
have a power outage and you have a lack
of circulation hopefully they're just
gonna be floating on top of that
solution well you also have to think of
the ergonomics rafts aren't not always
going to be elevated to waist height
people are gonna be bending over and
working on this you have to think of the
ergonomics and the workflow and think of
the people who are gonna be working
these systems so your decisions don't
have to be based on plant productivity
or plant biology you can base them off
the economics of the system to install
and maintain okay so that was
in this one we were at about an 8 inch
depth and in commonly I think if I would
say the range is from 4 to 6 inches up
to about 12 inches those do have a
question and if you have a questions at
any time you know as a faculty member I
have the gift of gab and I can talk at
length but I'm more than happy to answer
questions while we go if it's a more
organic approach to answering what
questions you have so please don't be
shy
so now that we've looked at systems when
we looked at cultivars I wanted to move
on to nutrient solution electrical
conductivity so the EC of a nutrient
solution measures the total amount of
fertilizer salts or ions in the
concentration that's how we monitor
fertilizers in hydroponic systems we're
not necessarily measuring specific
nutrients in their concentrations rather
we're measuring that over a total wall
concentration and along with pH this is
going to be something that we measure
and that we monitor and that we change
throughout production and try and keep
consistent to keep a consistent crop
quality but again the question is what
sort of an electrical conductivity do
you have to maintain in these herb
production systems and a lot of times an
herb system is going to be a poly
culture when we look at tomato
greenhouse you're usually growing just
Tomatoes or a cucumber greenhouse just
cucumbers you're in a lettuce greenhouse
it's normally going to be just lettuce
maybe some red and some green lettuce
but when you're when you have an herb
production program that's going to be a
poly culture where you have to grow a
number of different species because of
course you're gonna grow basil that's
that accounts for the vast majority of
culinary herb sales but you're also
going to have to grow other species
along with that because people don't
want to go to a basil producer and a
time producer and the rosemary producer
you have to produce everything so in
those polycultures what sort of
electrical conductivity can you maintain
your systems at to maintain the growth
and health of the crops that you're
growing so again for this system or for
this experiment we used NFT systems and
here you can see the range we used 5
nutrient solution electrical
conductivity x' from 0.5 to 4.0
when I'm doing these dose responses I
like to try and go from suboptimal to
nuclear so to speak and that that's a
pretty reasonable range as far as
electrical conductivity z' for
commercial production but then we also
wanted to conduct them under two
different lighting environments you know
the green house is dynamic with respect
to light you probably heard some of that
from dr. Mattson in his lab you know
light is what drives a lot of the
productivity in a greenhouse and how do
you have to adjust the nutrient solution
across different lighting environments
and so he ran this experiment under
treated for daily light integrals one
was about seven moles per day and in
iowa that would be what you'd get around
in a greenhouse in january then the
other DLI that we ran it under was about
sixteen moles per day that's a pretty
good day in april it also could simulate
a winter greenhouse in Iowa with no
light and perhaps a winter greenhouse
with supplemental lighting again we'll
talk more about the yield of growth of
herbs under light later but that's a
main driver of productivity as the
photosynthetic light so when we look at
basal grown under 0.5 to 4.0 under a low
DLI of around 7 moles per day or a high
D Li of around 16 moles per day even
though these look a little bit smaller
when we look after multiple replications
and we run regression analyses
electrical conductivity doesn't affect
the fresh mass of basal light does so we
had over twice the yield under that high
daily light integral as we did under
that low daily light integral so
photosynthetic might had a large impact
on the productivity of that crop but
electrical conductivity didn't and this
is something that for me was pretty
interesting because a lot of times I'll
talk to a grower and they'll say oh
trying to push my crop so I'm increasing
the fertilizer but that's not
necessarily a strategy that they can use
to increase the yield of their culinary
herbs what we did then what we did is
subsequently looked at the tissue
nutrient analysis of that crop trying to
figure out
what the concentration of these
nutrients were because in addition to
producing biomass we also want to have
healthy appearing biomass and the
appearance of a crop is going to be
largely influenced by tissue nutrient
concentrations you know if you're if you
have a plant that is deficient in
nitrogen you'll have chlorotic leaves if
you have deficient magnesium or iron and
basil you'll have intervener chlorosis
and that's going to render that crop
less marketable so when we look under
here the open symbols are the high daily
line integral and the closed symbols are
a low daily line integral and you can
see that the tissue nitrogen
concentration is increasing with
increasing nutrient solution EC and that
makes sense we've got a stronger
nutrient solution they've got greater
tissue nutrient concentrations but when
you look at the sufficiency range for
sweet basil we're trying to achieve four
to six percent nitrogen in the leaves
and you can see that under that 0.5
millisiemens electrical conductivity we
were above that we were well within that
sufficiency range and we didn't get any
super optimal ranges even though we were
starting to get close to that upper
limit but we were across electrical
conductivity x' we had healthy-appearing
tissue and if you look at across the
nutrients macro and micronutrients
generally speaking the concentrations
increase with electrical conductivity
now the concentration of calcium and
magnesium decreased with electrical
conductivity and there's two reasons why
you might see a reduction in calcium or
magnesium one it might be a dilution
effect as something gets bigger even the
concentration might increase the total
content or the content might be
increasing as well the concentration
could go down but we didn't have an
increase in mass rather what we think
happened is we adjust our nutrient
solutions with potassium hydroxide so
we've got a positively charged potassium
we've got positively charged calcium and
positively charged magnesium those three
nutrients often interact in nutrient
solutions so by having to make our
additions of base to raise the pH and
keep it within a target range we're
increasing the potassium concentration
that likely caused competition for
calcium and magnesium update you know
calcium and magnesium
have an antagonistic relationship but
Saudis callously
so does potassium as well with those
nutrients so again we were we were at or
above sufficiency ranges for all our
tissues nutrient concentrations now I
again we work in poly cultures and herbs
so I ran the same experiment we've got
cilantro idea and Lodi lime dill idea
lie low di we've also done this with
flat leaf parsley and now we've been
able to publish all the data and it was
the same for these other species just as
it was for the three different basil
species that we use we saw the same
effect that we didn't increase yield or
saw no promotion of growth with
increasing electrical conductivity in
the nutrient solution it was primarily
an effect of light so the the practical
implications is that as long as you're
adjusting your your nutrient solution EC
regularly that's why I've got a shot of
this doser here you can use this you can
run a low electrical conductivity and
you'll be just fine now if you're not
adjusting your nutrient solutions
regularly if you're doing it maybe say a
smaller operation three times a week or
something more periodic you may want to
run a higher electrical conductivity to
account for the depletion in between
additions but again these herbs are very
nutrient use efficient as far as their
uptake in their growth in response to
nutrients and if you think about a lot
of these herbs in their native
environments they they come from
relatively a less than optimal growing
environment so they likely have evolved
have efficient use of those mineral
nutrients that are available
okay so I've talked about cultivars
systems and nutrition now we're gonna
move into temperature and lights
temperature light lights going to
influence the growth that irreversible
increase in mass temperature primarily
increases or influences the rate of
development being that I'm a Minnesotan
it's so cold up there I'd like to think
that's why I'm so short it was just an
effective temperature but we can really
use air temperature and its effect on
crop development to schedule and predict
yields again this is going to vary among
species so when you look into the
literature
go into the USDA virtual grower they've
got a program called flowers on time now
and they've got dozens and dozens and
dozens of flora culture species that
have the time to flower based on air
temperature this model that you can use
and it's a great predictive tool but
again where is that for the herbs and so
that's what I want to set out to do when
we look at air temperature here we have
the common response this is just a
generic curve when we've got our rate of
growth a rate of development on our
y-axis and we've got air temperature
down here this represents the common
response of plants to air temperature
that base temperature the temperature at
or below which plant development stops
we've got our optimum temperature which
is that temperature that results in the
maximum rate of development and then
we've got or I'm sorry our optimum
temperature at that maximum rate of
development and then our maximum
temperature which is the temperature at
or above which plant development stops
now between the base temperature in the
optimal temperature we have a linear
range and this is great because linear
ranges are where we are many times in
greenhouse temperatures we're often
within that linear range the other
benefit is that a linear model y equals
MX plus B is relatively easy to use as
far as a predictive tool for growth and
development so I spent a couple of years
modeling the growth of herbs in response
to air temperatures we had five
temperatures that we use 11 to 35
degrees Celsius and we had 16 species
and cultivars including 4 basal species
to cilantro cultivars and then a host of
other culinary herbs thank you to the
students who watered these plants
particularly those that were in the 35
seat chamber but right now I'm getting
around to writing up the rest of this
data because I don't want it to die in
in vain because of the amount of
maintenance that this took to make this
experiment go but this is what we ended
up seeing you know we got and we got the
data leaf unfolding fresh mass dry mass
and height for all of these species and
you can see that the response of this
lemon basil pretty much follows that
June
at curve but i hand-write it's going to
increase from the base temperature which
is just a little bit below 11 up until
that optimal which is right around 30
after which point it's going to decrease
so lemon-basil as well as the three
other basal species we had is a cold
sensitive warm growing crop warm growing
because it has a high optimal
temperature alternatively basal and flat
leaf parsley you can see that it's got a
more moderate optimal temperature should
be ground a little bit cooler you can
also see that even though it was growing
slowly in those cold temperatures the
growth was greater and it's more
tolerant of those cold temperatures so
again these photos compliment that curve
but how we use this data here we have
the fresh mass accumulation rate for
dill so it's the grams per day of fresh
mass using this we can solve for an
optimal right at 23 C then what we do is
we exclude those super optimal
temperatures and then we put together
that nice linear model we can calculate
the base temperature being right at 8
degrees Celsius and then we can use the
linear model to predict growth so just
to show you for an example if we were to
use our data on sweet basil we can
predict basil harvest we generally plant
right around a 1 gram seedling that's
the shoot fresh mass of the seedlings
were producing usually about two weeks
old and we're trying to get at least 21
point 3 grams which would be 3/4 ounce I
like to envision every basil shoot being
the shoot that will fill that 3/4 ounce
clamshell packaging which is the most
widely sold herb so again here we have
that response of sweet basil looks a lot
like lemon basil I optimal temperature
sensitive to cold and here's our linear
range so we take that curve we exclude
those temperatures that are super
optimal we've got our basil fresh mass
gain fresh grams per day equals point
zero eight seven times the air temp
minus the intercept point nine eight
five and using this model if we were to
grow at 18 20 or 22 degrees these would
be our fresh mass rates meaning we would
achieve that 3/4 ounce size at 21 point
three grams shoot at 35 days 27 days or
22 days as we grow from 18 to 22 okay so
this is a tool that growers can use
again these linear models to predict the
growth of basil and estimate harvest or
if they want to make changes in their
energy use changes in their air
temperature they can estimate the impact
that this is going to have on the crop
time for their herb crops so again the
herb responses to air temperature vary
both in the magnitude of change as well
as their base temperature in their
optimal temperature these predictive
models are going to be useful for
predicting changes as well as informing
change that you're trying to do you can
also group your crops by temperature if
you've got a large enough production
facility and you have multiple bays you
could have a warmer greenhouse for basil
to try and finish those crops more
quickly and have more turns but then you
can have a slightly moderate greenhouse
for things like parsley and dill
chamomile these other herbs so you can
start to group crops based on their
actual requirements okay so we just
talked about development I want to talk
a little bit more about light this is
really where a lot of my work has been
focused it part of that comes from my
background at the University of
Minnesota I worked on light as well as
at Purdue University I also worked on
light it also has to do with the
location that I'm in being in the
northern latitude the United States lice
light can often be one of the more
limiting factors in greenhouse crop
production and again temperature affects
development but light really affects the
mass of plants see that's what
commercial producers are selling they're
selling mass if we were an ornamental
grower we're selling units that look
aesthetically pleasing you know in an
appealing looking container a
nice-looking flat but with food crops
were selling mass in ornamental crops we
often have to try and justify the cost
of lighting using supplemental light
because it's got to have a translation
and the quality of the crop that will
get a higher premium but this is value
proposition is much easier in food crops
because we sell mass primarily we're
interested in the quantity of photos
static light now I'm gonna talk a little
bit more about light quality and
spectrum but it's the photosynthetic
light and the quantity of it that's
going to dictate the amount of mass
that's produce day length and photo
period is it can be a concern especially
when we're trying to inhibit flowering
of many of our culinary herbs or induce
flowering of some of the recreational
herbs but we're primarily looking at the
quantity of light so again here we have
I did some worker actually my PhD
student started his PhD on light and
herbs screening the responses and
modeling growth in response to daily
line integral daily light integral is
the cumulative amount of photosynthetic
light over the course of a day and we
tried to use a range of DL eyes we went
as low as about two moles per day up to
approximately 20 moles per day now for
those of you thinking like I you
wouldn't have two moles in a greenhouse
I encourage you to come ice fishing this
winter in Minnesota and you'll
absolutely have to mole days inside of
the greenhouse it's very possible we
didn't go above 20 moles because above
20 moles even though light could be
promoting growth for somebody's species
in a greenhouse that's when you're gonna
start to reduce light for thermal
management and temperature management so
we tried to use that range of DL eyes
that are most useful for managing
photosynthetic light and we focused on
eight different species of herbs from
basil to time and as is probably no
surprise the yield of herbs increases
with increasing daily light integral
again here we've got the eight species
basil cilantro parsley dill mint sage
thyme and oregano and four five out of
the eight species we had a linear
increase in yield in response to daily
light integral okay for three of the
species we did start to get to a super
optimal point okay so we started to get
to a point where they were getting
saturated with light and yield started
to Plateau or even diminish at some
point so even though yield does increase
for all these species it doesn't
increase the same magnitude oh sorry let
me go back actually so since we reach
those optimal with mint parsley and sage
we can classify these much like
classifying herbs with their temperature
responses as cool growing moderate
growing and warm growing species we can
classify herbs based on their lighting
requirements so none of the herbs that
we found you were growing under would be
classified as low light plants requiring
5 to 10 moles per day 3 of the species
we consider moderate light plants
requiring between 10 to 20 moles per day
the remaining 5 species they're either
going to be high or very high light
plants we can't classify them more
precisely because we didn't reach that
optimal light level so they're going to
be one of those two which is going to be
again highlight crop especially for a
greenhouse like I was saying increasing
light increases the yield but the
magnitude of change varies across the
species so let's say for example if we
look at basil now if we look at basil
and we add let's go from 8 moles to 12
moles of light okay in that we're adding
four moles of light with supplemental
HPS light that's why I use the color
coordinated yellow we're gonna increase
our yield by 40 grams okay alternatively
if we add that same amount of
supplemental light to the oregano crop
that we're growing we're still adding
four moles of light we're only
increasing your yield by six grams same
amount of light same amount of energy
input but the amount of return on
investment is going to be much lower for
oregano so one of the ways that we
wanted to try and convey this more
simply is people aren't necessarily
gonna be growing under the same
conditions that we have the same crop
time so we calculated the power
productivity which is a really fancy way
of just distilling what's important from
this and power productivity is just the
yield per mole of light so you take your
grams per plant and then you calculate
out on a per meter squared basis what it
is then you've got your total crop time
per day then you've also got that
average DLI in moles per meter squared
per day you cancel out the meters cancel
out the days you divide the grams by the
moles and you get power productivity
grams per mole just gonna be one single
value and using this value it reflects
that example that I just showed you on
the grass itself basil power
productivity of 6.3 grams per mole
oregano power productivity of 0.4 grams
per mole ok so the reason that this is
useful is if you're thinking about using
supplemental light you can look at which
crops are going to bring you the most
return as far as biomass back for photon
provided all the plants are going to
respond well to additional lighting but
you have to think about that bill that's
going to be paid at the end of the month
so again the light requirements herbs
are going to be either moderate light
requiring plants or high or very high
light requiring plants the para
productivity varies widely you're gonna
have things like oregano and thyme that
are gonna have relatively low output per
unit and photosynthetic light in so
again we can use these results to do
some predicts on predictions on yield as
well as determine the effects of
changing the DLI or adding supplemental
light yes you so generally if we go back
to that 3/4 ounce package they're
generally marketed at the same price
point so there that you'll see
differences sometimes in like a
lemongrass you know cuz that's generally
going to be imported and that will cost
more but generally the clamshell pricing
is uniform across that suite of products
does that the dress your question cool
so now that I've talked about the
importance of light how are we gonna
increase light and an aside from going
up and making sure you have clean blades
and materials and minimizing the amount
of hanging baskets overhead that's just
gonna maximize transition or
transmission of light the only way you
can appreciably increase light is going
to be to provide supplemental lighting
traditionally HPS lamps are going to be
the most useful for increasing the DLI
in a greenhouse but there's increasing
popularity in LED lights partially
because of their energy efficiency also
well mostly because of their energy
efficiency and their long luminous
lifespan how long they're gonna last but
also they have narrow spectra when we
think about having those narrow spectra
we can start to think about doing
things with I know a lot of people in
dr. Mattson lab are doing cool things
with specific wavelengths blue red far
red we want to do the same thing with
herbs so we wanted to look at
supplemental light and its effect on
plants with a special reference to the
proportion of blue light so we took
three supplemental light sources high
pressure sodium an LED light with a low
percentage of blue 7% the balance of 93
percent red and then LEDs with a high
percentage of blue 30% blue and 70
percent red then we want to look at the
growth and flavor components of three
herbs basil and dill and flat leaf
parsley and here we have at the end of
three weeks growth we have our HBS plant
our led with low blue and our led with
high blue you can see that those plants
grown under the LEDs are more compact
that's partially going to be because of
the increased proportion of blue light
which usually results in more compact
growth it also might have to do with a
little bit of a temperature effect on
plants with those HBS Brown plants
having a warmer temperature during the
day and stretching a little bit but we
don't sell sizes in hydroponic plants
again we sell mass and when we looked at
the shoot fresh and dry mass we had no
significant difference in the shoot
fresh and dry mass across our three
lighting treatments but we did have is a
significant difference in some of the
polyphenolics that are in that basil you
can see that in general using the LEDs
with the greater proportion of blue
light enhanced the polyphenol a
concentration in basil not all had
statistical differences but you can see
that increasing trend and the reason
being is we love herbs because of their
defense mechanism those compounds that
are in herbs that flavor our dishes are
what what herbs normally use to respond
to stresses and avoid orb every blue
light 450 nanometers is a high-energy
wavelength and by using higher
concentrations of blue light that's
going to enhance basically the stress
response and be uploading or out
regulating the synthesis of some of
these compounds that again are
attributed to the flavour and basil we
saw the same
Sara a similar trend with dill and we
saw another similar trend with parsley
so this got is excited we see there's a
promotive effects of blue light on some
of these flavor compounds so we wanted
to take it another step further and just
see you know what even more blue light
would do and look at the dose response
of basil to blue light so the follow-up
experiment to this we went inside of a
growth chamber I'm just gonna leave this
photo of Will Ferrel up here a little
bit longer while I explain this maybe
that wasn't me na younger Dee and we we
went inside of a growth chamber and we
went from 100% light to 100% blue light
in 20 percent increments and we grew new
fire basil in a deep flow like system so
here we've got zero red or I'm sorry
zero blue hundred percent red and then
we're slowly increasing the blue by 20
percent until we finally get to hundred
percent blue and then we did grow a
chamber underneath white light as well
so after three weeks of growth here our
basil plants again neuf are going from
zero to 100% blue light so earlier and
oh yeah it was the fluence white light I
can't remember what the exact spectrum
is I know I've got that in the
manuscript I can share that with you so
I forget the proportion of blue light
that it is but it was seen as white LED
in the the other array were fluent
arrays as well in the previous slide you
saw those plants growing under LEDs or
shorter and more compact most likely due
to the blue light and you see that for
as we go from zero to 80% blue light
then all of a sudden you have that
really tall plant and I'll get to that
in the next slide and that's under 100
percent blue light and then there is our
white light grown plant and again here's
the data showing the height decreasing
with basil as you go from zero to 80%
blue and then getting a lot taller
underneath that 100 percent blue and it
wasn't a leaf unfolding effect we had
the same number of nodes on both of the
plants rather what happens is the fight
preying photo equilibria when you're
under 100% blue changes and it actually
promotes stem elongation when you're
under 100% blue and when at first as an
advisor you see this it's like well blue
light makes things shorter my grad
student must have done something wrong
but thankfully he did and this is also
validated by other research ricardo
hernandez and cherry Kubota demonstrated
this with cucumber seedlings and so
again this is a common response when
you're going under 100% blue light in a
sole source lighting environment not
necessarily 100% blue in a greenhouse
now there is a bit of a yield penalty
though as we go we drew with higher
proportions of blue light than we did in
our previous experiment you can see that
it's going to leaf dry mass decreases as
you increase that percentage of blue the
other problem is we're growing more stem
proportionately so here we have our leaf
dry mass or stem dry mass in our root
dry mass and here we have the leaf mass
ratio stem mass ratio in the root mass
ratio so the percentage of biomass in
each of those organs and you can see
that even though there's no statistical
effect and maybe a slight downward trend
the proportion of stem production
increases under blue light that's
because we're getting less root
production and less leaf production but
it is again growing proportionally more
stem mass and again that's not the
desirable part of basil when we look at
the gas exchange you can see that still
model conductance intercellular co2 and
transpiration all increase with blue
light you also have an increase in
photosynthesis up to 60% after which
there starts to be a slight decline now
you'll see that while photosynthesis was
increasing the total mass was decreasing
that's because this was not done on
whole canopy photosynthesis this was
done on a per leaf area or just this was
a leaf photosynthesis and if you
actually go back and look at those basal
shots the basal have smaller leaves as
the proportion of blue light is
increasing and so although you have a
slight promotive effect of blue light up
to a point on
photosynthesis and a reduction your
total photosynthetic area on the plant
is decreasing underneath higher blue
light because you have smaller foliage
so total canopy photosynthesis is
decreasing but when we look at again
flavonoid concentrations in response to
blue light we see those same increases
with increasing proportion of blue light
again
we were working before between seven and
thirty percent but here you can see
going from zero to a hundred percent we
have a promotive effect of all those
compounds in basal foliage again with
the potential to grow a more flavorful
plant so when we look at supplemental
lighting HPS and leds are comparable for
improving yield you need to consider
things though like lamp density you can
use fewer HBS lamps than you do LEDs so
you might need to consider that
increasing the blue light in spectra and
narrow spectral lights may add value by
enhancing flavor of basil but it does
come at a cost at a certain point when
if you're using a high enough proportion
you're trying to maximize some of the
flavor compounds you're actually gonna
have a diminished shoot fresh mass the
good thing is that you can actually grow
basil on a very small Center you can
grow it on a three or a four inch center
if you're doing a short crop time so you
can potentially modify the amount of
time that you have or the amount of
density of the basil in your growing
area to make up for some of the yield
penalties under that higher beam light
so to kind of wrap up this this
whirlwind of culinary herbs select high
yielding cultivars select your system
based on the cost of the system or
operational functional functionality
with your employees manage your nutrient
solutions to minimize imbalances and
solution exchanges so make your EC
management more about the concentration
of absolute nutrients and you can do
that and stretch your nutrient solution
is longer by using a lower EC more
consistently the temperature and the D
Li models that we've developed can
hopefully improve scheduling and
predictive predicting yield of your crop
and then finally select your
supplemental light sources based on your
goals are you trying to produce viable
biomass are you trying to produce a more
flavorful product
so I get to talk about all this but I
don't get to do much of the work at all
and so I would like to completely
recognize Pete Lawler our greenhouse
manager make sure everything is always
running seven days a week 52 weeks a
year and then in particular for these
three or four the studies that I
presented here today
Kelly Walters Nix flax and Alex Lippmann
all played a really large hand and
actually doing the work and then we were
supported by farm tech Asus Johnny's and
jr. Peters so so thanks to all of them
for making all this work possible thank
you so much for the invitation to come
here and with that I'd like to take any
questions that you might have about
culinary herbs what is the most crucial
thing is it necessarily going to be nor
is it going to be the polyphenolics
is a classic professor answer it depends
you know it depends on who you're
growing for if you're basil is going
into Cisco into into like a large
agribusiness then it's going to be
yields if you're targeting a more local
market coops restaurants then you
absolutely could be looking for flavor
over yield but it's oh so so it does
depend on your target market I think I
would like to say that we don't need to
choose and let's find a high yielding
flavorful basil because I think that's
what people really want you know
Genovese taste great knew far holds up
really well so I would say it's probably
the marriage of both of those a
flavorful but high yielding cultivar
with a lot of leaf area not a lot of
stems Geneva say have any questions
Geneva do you have any questions Oh have
you conjunct have we have conducted
sensory analyses with the Department of
Food Science and human nutrition we're
still working to get those results back
because that was a separate master
and a separate P I who is taking our
basel away from us in running the study
so we're we're still waiting to see if
that translates because we could be
picking it up on really expensive
equipment but I'm not sure if if if
people are actually sensing that so
that's a it's a absolutely great
question yeah trim you see boss just
like I preferentially use micro mo
instead of foot-candle and don't
recognize foot-candle I'm a major fan of
a one a one-and-done harvest the reason
being when you think about pest
management I don't like having old tired
plant material in a greenhouse so I
think it's best even though you have an
increased cost with planting you know
with substrate I think about quick
cropping and getting those basil plants
out of the greenhouse and starting anew
I just think that's fundamentally a
better production approach because of
the insurance that you have and we're
really limited with controlled
environment food crops with how we can
control pests and so prevention is
really the best way so I just
fundamentally umpires towards a single
harvest but people people will get a
second harvest out of their crop is it
is is the mass production like faster I
can't answer that question it the
texture in the flavor will change on
second cut crops you know they tend to
flower quicker on that second cut and
generally when a basil starts to induce
flowering it'll start to upregulate some
of the production of those compounds but
it can get to the point of being too
much and we're on our linear models with
blue light is too much I can't answer
that question so some people will prefer
a spicier basil but if it's in a flower
earlier you get less leaves form before
that flower so in a way your yields
might go down even further as opposed to
planting a younger plant that's farther
away from initiating flowers yes
temperature have you looked at our
similar play crops that are currently
similar temperatures do they also grow
under this similar light constraints
that's a good question um
right now I'm now that my tenure
decision is done I get to revise all my
old data and now I get to start to write
papers again and so I'm actually
bringing out all that old temperature
data and starting to do the modeling on
that so the three moderate light crops
were parsley sage and mint and I can't
recall parsley is a moderate temperature
crop of an optimal somewhere between 21
and 24 C and it's also moderate light
plant but you can't whereas the other
ones are high light plants even though
they're the moderate temperature crops
so I don't know that I can completely
answer answer that question yet but
Kelly Walter is that stood that I
mentioned for her PhD she's actually
working on some interactions of light
and temperature and I think she's doing
basil parsley and dill I think those are
her main three crops so she might be
able to talk a little bit more or at
least later this year when her work
comes out that might speak to those
interactions more and see how they
interact because we only did a single
factor experiment oh hi Anna how are you
doing
she was an undergrad
it might seem okay okay sorry sorry
in economic cuz it's not up there sorry
I'm pointing at it like you see it how
far saturated is the market for herbs
like basil it seems like some areas like
between cities there were tons of
choices in the produce section for local
hydroponic herbs so this is what I'm
going to tell you Santa might not be
real one of the things that happens with
herbs is it's often very common to
resell herbs where producers will bring
in boxes of field Don basil from Hawaii
and then they'll repackage it in their
packaging so as far as whether they're
locally grown like the like Anna was
talking about in the Twin Cities I can't
answer that a bit saturated because I
know for sure I know of one local Twin
Cities grower who shall remain and
remain nameless should say grower that's
repackaging field grown basil as their
own product they're not saying that it's
locally grown they're saying they're a
local company but they're passing it off
as local basil and I know that at least
one of our producers in Iowa it
it was like when I saw the price tag on
my Christmas present when I saw his
yield grown basil people are still
bringing infield grown crops and just
marketing and under their clamshell when
they have depressions in production like
in the winter or some people are just
doing it as a marketing scheme there's
nothing wrong with reselling a product
but I think that it's not generally as
forthcoming as if it was resold versus
if it was grown in the state so so I
can't answer that question I do still
think that there's an opportunity for
local production just based on the
volume consumed yeah mint you can thank
the mojito for that that's not a joke I
mean it absolutely is mitch is
absolutely the second most popular herb
and a lot of that has to do with popular
cocktails this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu